era sólo cuestión de tiempo los médicos
han confirmado lo inevitable el primer
caso positivo de la variante un micrón
de el coronavirus ha llegado a
territorio francés
o al menos a dos países mozambique y
realizó una escala en sudáfrica fue
puesto en aislamiento al igual que su
entorno presenta los síntomas clásicos
tiene tos dolor muscular y está muy
cansado
efectivo el caso se registró en la isla
francesa a la reunión un territorio de
ultramar situado a más de 9000
kilómetros del continente y se produce
mientras cada vez más países confirman
nuevos casos de la variante entre ellos
japón que ya anunció el lunes el cierre
de sus fronteras a todos los extranjeros
durante un mes en eeuu el presidente joe
biden hizo un llamado a la calma
insistiendo en que no había necesidad de
entrar en pánico tendremos que
enfrentarnos a esta nueva amenaza igual
que a las anteriores
varios países y han prohibido los viajes
hacia y desde los estados del sur de
áfrica
ellos eeuu reino unido y la unión
europea- una medida que ha sido
criticada por el gobierno sudafricano
los científicos y la o&m ese tipo no se
puede culpar a la población de áfrica
por el nivel y moralmente debajo de
vacunas disponibles en el continente y
no se le debe penalizar por identificar
y compartir información científica y
sanitaria crucial con el mundo sin
huerto world otros países han elogiado a
sudáfrica por su rápida detección de la
omicron a principios de este mes los
primeros indicios sugieren que la
variante es más contagiosa que sus
predecesoras y aunque hasta ahora no se
ha relacionado con ninguna muerte los
científicos dicen que necesitan más
tiempo para determinar su riesgo general